[Applause]
[Music]
China is already a giant this country is
the largest trading power in the world
they need the world with hundreds of
products and have one of the largest
foreign currency reserves in the entire
planet not even the Petro monarchies in
the Persian Gulf can compete with this
giant country and with all of this it
isn't surprising to find some honest sea
states that China will surpass the
United States as the leading economic
power bars they're gonna do that with a
lot more inhabitants however we usually
figure out a very important thing and
this is that GDP well it's not
everything economic power the real power
is closely related to corporate power
and when it comes to that China is still
a long way from reaching the levels of
the United States if we look at the top
100 largest companies in the world 56 of
them are American and only 11 are
Chinese and this is something to really
bear in mind because multinationals are
in control of foreign investments and of
80% of the world's exports now the big
question is what's gonna happen to these
Chinese companies in the future how are
things changing and what can we really
expect these are some of the questions
though we're going to be answering in
today's video
the Chinese giant's development
the Chinese economy has had an
impressive growth rate in the last three
decades and key to this was the concept
of them being the world's Factory this
is what China is known for they are
known as a country that has become a
world power and has lifted hundreds of
thousands of people from poverty with a
relatively simple premise producing
everything and producing it at a low
cost toys electronics tools clothing
when you enter a store you are going to
find hundreds of products with something
in common and that's that they are all
manufactured in massive industrial areas
located all over China however in order
for a country to really be the leading
economic power these companies need to
start producing much more complex
products man's they will have to stop
competing on cost and start looking at
for higher added value this can include
the production of things like capital
assets planes medical devices and
computer processes that driverless car
Intel's driving the future traffic light
street lamps business problems on the
cloud and the cloud runs on Intel
and today all these sectors are
dominated by the large multinational
companies of the United States South
Korea Europe and Japan much that is true
the many leading products are
manufactured in China for example the
iPhone but this is not exactly true
because what China actually doing is
more like the assembly what this means
is that the more complex parts they're
bought from other countries and then
they are simply put together in China so
you better illustrate this consider this
each year China imports more than 200
billion dollars in semiconductors which
are essential in the manufacturing of
mobile devices just for a comparison
that is more money than what the entire
country spends on petrol
however Chinese companies have made many
advances today
1/4 of all exports are capital goods
such as machines for example or
high-tech products in some sectors like
telecommunications wind turbines or
high-speed trains Chinese companies are
the world leaders
and it's not just that because Chinese
companies are also learning how to make
it in the international market the great
Chinese conquest 2016 was the 40th
anniversary of the ends of the Cultural
Revolution this was a terrifying
campaign which Mao organized in order to
purify the revolution and finish off all
remnants of capitalism in Chinese
society well since then things have
changed a lot so much that China is only
behind the United States in terms of
numbers of multinational companies
companies in this country they're
starting to make it into global markets
and well they're doing it really really
well
2016 Chinese companies spent an
incredible amount of money 225 billion
dollars in purchase of foreign companies
in Europe in the United States alone
they acquired more than 450 companies
these Chinese companies are buying all
kinds of businesses mining companies
banks oil companies pharmaceutical
companies agricultural companies even
luxury hotel chains jewelry companies
and football clubs yep yeah that right
dear viewer the Chinese have even bought
in to Milan and that is just one example
Manchester City gets a four hundred
million dollar Chinese investment deal
but if there is one thing in particular
that the Chinese love to invest in well
that would be developing countries even
though Australia and the United States
are the two countries that received the
most in Chinese investment dollars more
than half of all Chinese investment is
made in emerging countries located in
Asia Africa Latin America and the Middle
East so we could almost say that the
more risky the country the more willing
the Chinese are to invest in it now this
might surprise you but this this is not
the end of the story Chinese companies
are also starting to compete hard well
if there was only one Chinese company in
the top 100 most valuable companies in
2006 there were 14 by the Year 2015 and
take a look at the smartphone industry
up until recently having a Chinese phone
well it was a bit weird right well today
the four main Chinese manufacturers Oppo
Huawei vivo and Xiao Mei aren't just
more famous than they were a few years
ago they also take more than 10% of the
world's profits in this industry and
this is a figure that is growing more
and more every single year and if you
want another example well you just have
to look to Lenovo which is a Chinese
multinational company that was born just
a few years ago and indeed it bought the
laptop division of IBM and is now the
largest computer company in the world
and they even supply equipment to the
Pentagon and had even more examples
there's higher the biggest manufacturer
of household appliances or cough koa
company thus acquiring land all over the
world like sugar cane plantations in
Australia French vineyards or soy
plantations in Brazil and then there's
Guinea a car company which you might not
have heard of but it actually bought out
Volvo in 2010 yeah Volvo that legendary
Swedish car company is now property of a
Chinese company
but if there is a sector where China is
really getting ahead
it is against all the odds the internet
and I say against all odds here because
as you probably know China is subject to
complete control of its internet by the
Chinese government with something known
as the Great Firewall this blocks access
to Facebook Google and The Economist to
name just three however on the other
hand in China it's pretty normal to do
everything via apps for example when you
visit China you rarely pay with credit
cards the most common thing is to pay
with a mobile phone using the app WeChat
this is something of a super app that is
like an all-in-one Facebook PayPal Gmail
Twitter etc by the way we chat is also
owned by 10 cent one of the top 15 most
valuable companies in the world which is
also the world's largest supplier of
online games and one of the largest
shareholders of Tesla
so by now you are probably realizing
that oh yes the Chinese they are
everywhere as for another example of
their success do consider Alibaba an
e-commerce company that brings in 450
billion dollars every year and in China
alone this company has 400 million
clients and well there's Napoleon said
let's China sleep for when she wakes she
will shake the world but before we all
get scared just have a think about what
it means it means more competition it
means better prices better products and
faster technological developments as
consumers we can benefit a great deal
from this transition now obviously it
does have plenty of risks - or at least
this is what US intelligence agencies
are warning according to the house
permanent Select Committee on
Intelligence is report Chinese companies
cannot be trusted to be free a foreign
state influence and thus pose a security
threat to the United States and to our
systems and then there's the risk of
companies which are going to have more
and more competition although they're
also going to have more and more
opportunities - which we previously
discussed in the video that we're
linking to you on the screen now but
let's not get too ahead of ourselves
Chinese companies are still far behind
in technological terms and they are in
debt and well a great deal of it Chinese
corporate debt levels are too high but
it will take time to bring them down to
more manageable levels and this this is
not the end of it don't forget that
China is a dictatorship and this means
that the government has too much power
when it comes to corporate decisions
further the government's is pretty
arbitrary and is really unpredictable
for example a few years ago the
government encouraged Chinese companies
do try the international market and they
would loan them as much money as they
needed to do so but now they've decided
they want to do the opposite if Chinese
company wants to buy out a foreign
company they need the approval of the
Chinese Communist Party and there are
new tough limitations on money leaving
the country further to that we have to
mention the censorship the legal
uncertainty trade obstacles and the bad
reputation of Chinese products and so on
and so forth so we can say that right
now the United States's position as Lee
is not in particular danger unless
something changes that is more dramatic
than we are currently seeing long-term
though well who knows so I really hope
you enjoyed that video please do hit
that like button if you did and do not
forget to subscribe if you haven't
already brand new videos every Monday
and every Thursday and don't forget to
do check out the reconsider media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
video that are not mine and as always
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
[Applause]